hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone there's so many questions for
this week's Walking Dead finale Q&A you
know lots of awesome stuff to talk about
a lot of big announcements especially
going into the spinoff and season six
I'll just I'll start with the Jon Hamm
stuff first just to clarify the reason
everyone thinks that Jon Hamm has been
cast as negan is because in an interview
he said he would love to play negan and
because Mad Men is ending and it's also
an AMC show it's much easier for them to
bring him into Walking Dead than say
like an outside actor that they haven't
worked with before I would love to see
him play negan but it's not confirmed
like he hasn't been cast as negan I'll
talk a little bit about the spin-off
series at the end of the QA
along with a couple of announcements
Walking Dead related announcements I
also saw a lot of you guys freaking out
whenever I posted my Daryl Dixon video
on Sunday and that was just like a
normal bonus video I guess people got
freaked out because they thought that
Daryl might die so don't worry I don't
do crazy stuff like that and I don't get
to watch episodes early so even whenever
I posted that video I hadn't seen the
episode yet and the questions that I
picked for the Q&A today are just like a
mixture of spin-off in finale stuff so
here we go first question ambidextrous
asks I thought that this spinoff would
be about Clementine yeah I think I think
I mean they'll continue to make the
Walking Dead game and they'll just
explore her story in that Skybound is
like pushing the limits in terms of what
they do with the Walking Dead license so
there will be plenty more Clementine but
it will mostly take place in the video
games that doesn't mean they won't ever
bring her on to the TV show it just
means you know like not anytime soon so
here we go next question John BK 34 asks
why did Sasha lay down on all those dead
walkers mostly because she is completely
messed up they're all completely PTSD
right now to varying degrees you could
argue that she laid down on the walkers
in the pit like after she put them in
the pit because she finally felt safe
like she's not gonna feel safe till
they're all dead and buried so once she
all dumped them in there she felt a
little reprieve like a very brief
reprieve until she swung back to
super-crazy again if you want to link it
to her going to the church I think she
also kind of hit her lowest point like
she was finally just like I can't do
this anymore that's why she sought
father Gabriel's help like she just
wanted help making sense of what was
going on in her head clearly that didn't
go so well at least until Maggie showed
up next question Lexi asks I was a
little annoyed they didn't show
Glenn escaping from the walkers can he
teleport now this was this is by far
like one of the most common complaints
like what happened to Glenn how did he
get away how much money does everyone
wanna bet that this is gonna be like one
of the number one questions that Robert
Kirkman in The Walking Dead people get
asked at comic-con this summer
really I think the conclusion they want
us to draw is that Glenn overpowered
them and was lucky enough not to sustain
any injuries from the walkers that would
have accelerated him turning the gunshot
wound alone was enough to kill him if he
hadn't been treated right away like if
he would have passed out he would have
just bled out and turned so I think he
got like some crazy adrenaline rush from
trying to escape from the walkers
usually when people sustained trauma
like that you don't want them to pass
out that's why they say to try and keep
someone awake when they get injured
really badly
next question George asks what do you
think that the writers have planned for
Morgan well so they're doing a lot more
comic book stuff he has a comic book
story associated with Alexandria so I
think what they'll do is they'll adapt
some of that and then they'll give him
some of the story from characters that
they've changed from the comics a lot of
the Alexandria stuff is straight out of
the comics but some of the characters
aren't the same as the characters in the
comics so they're kind of mixing and
matching just a little bit if you do
want to start reading the comics too
far-gone is a good place to start just
because that gets into Alexandria stuff
that's kind of where we are in the
timeline right now next question more
Morgan stuff killer plays asks so is
Morgan the guy who killed all those
people with the W's on their foreheads I
assume you're talking about like the
walkers with all the W's on their
foreheads that we've met in the past no
I think the Wolves did that and then
carved the W's into their heads based on
what they said they said that they run
into people every couple of weeks like
they've roam around like the scavengers
in the comics I think when they find
people they carve the W's into their
heads and then they kill them so you
have a combination of them graffitiing
people that are still alive and walkers
at the same time if Morgan was killing
the walkers with the W's on their heads
it was only because they're attacking
him next question Raphael asks was it
just me or did you notice the displeased
face Morgan put on when he saw Rick was
killing porchdick Morgan said to Daryl
all life is precious and he didn't even
kill the wolves that were trying to kill
him
yes I definitely think that they're
gonna address that in the season six
premiere the funny twist is is that the
last time we saw Morgan he was the crazy
one and
Rick was the voice of reason and now
they kind of switch roles or at least
that's what it seems like Tamura and
based on this look on his face he came
on Rick just as Rick gave this big
speech about how all the Alexandrians
needed to get way more extreme so I
think Morgan is gonna be at odds with
that agenda he's got this really Zen
thing going on so I think he and Rick
are gonna clash a little bit at the
beginning of season six what I'm hoping
is is that Morgan will see the Wolves
whose lives he spared he'll see that
they brought all these 18-wheelers to
the walls and he's like oh I probably
should have killed those guys when I had
the chance like yes all life is precious
but there are consequences sometimes the
lives that you save or the people that
you don't kill turn out to be really
really bad people next question Totoro
asks hey Toder hasn't gone do you think
that the walkers in the trailers were
part of the wolves or are they victims I
would say probably combination that's
actually an interesting idea like did
they find people kill them carve w's
into their heads and then stuff him in
the trailers there are so many walkers
there I think a lot of them they just
found roaming around like they were
already walkers they marked him up and
then led them into the 18-wheelers but I
do you think they killed some people
since they met them and then put them in
the trailers it seems that their group
has always been pretty small they did
kill Little Red Riding Hood here so he
might be in one of those trailers now
too
keep your eyes peeled for the season 6
premiere whenever those 18-wheelers roll
up next question Fionan asks what do you
think that Rick is gonna do with the
people of Alexandria to make them
tougher I think just basic survival
training just really practical stuff
that also includes like security
measures people Manning the gate keeping
someone in the tower like Sasha might
stay on tower duty there's really basic
stuff like that like the way they move
around at groups like nobody walks
around alone by themselves even if
they're inside the community next
question
David asks why did the wolf guy have a
gun with no bullets that's a good
question he it sounds like he's
scavengers like they don't have a ton of
supplies and he didn't really want to
kill Morgan he said he was gonna bring
Morgan back with him you could argue
that he was gonna turn him into Walker
and stick him in one of the 18-wheelers
mostly though I think he just doesn't
have a lot of supplies like they're
always scavenging for stuff that's why I
think they're the scavengers from the
comics so it's not like they have like a
giant stockpile of weapons and ammo next
question Rose asks if fear the walking
dead in the walking dead are in the same
universe does that mean at the beginning
of the outbreak and fear the walking
dead
in the in the spinoff Rick is still in a
coma actually yeah that's correct he
would be in a coma because he was in a
coma like his coma overlapped with the
outbreak just to be clear that the
spin-off show will catch up with the
timeline of the main show eventually but
I don't know if that's gonna happen at
the end of season one or season two or
some future season they just said that
it would start in the early days of the
outbreak and would eventually catch up
with the main show next question
Tony asks why was Michonne's katana off
the wall mount had she taken it to the
meeting well if you remember that was
what porchdick brought to the meeting
and accidentally killed Deanna's husband
with there were a lot of questions about
how he got Michonne's katana I think
what happened is is that he went to
Michonne and Rick's house like remember
that are all sharing houses looking for
Rick didn't find him and then saw the
katana on the wall pulled it down and
thought that he was gonna use it to go
after Rick with like he was probably
just super drunk went over to Rick's
house looking to start a fight and they
just was like oh there's a katana on the
wall here I'm gonna take that and they
just stumbled through the streets
looking for Rick till he saw the meeting
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I think my next bonus video or my
next Walking Dead video is gonna be my
season six predictions I'll try to post
that in the next couple of days I've got
a few more videos to get through before
that but be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will do a new round of the
giveaway whenever I post that video too
which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winners there's actually a double
because it was the finale so Mega Buster
man and shining Polaris you both went
$20 Amazon gift cards just be sure to DM
me on the back end of my channel for a
contact info if you guys have a question
about where to find that that's on the
about page like you just you send a
message I just say that because a lot of
people are confused about you know where
YouTube's moved the PM button to change
the interface just a little bit what's
happening next is I'm gonna post my
agents of shield video because that
happened last night and then I'll post
my arrow video probably Thursday morning
in case you guys haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my top 10 video from
the finale and you can click here for my
top 10 Daryl Dixon moments not including
the finale stuff so there's no like
chain whip in there so thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight